our US army green beret and author of
separated at birth how North Korea
became the evil twin next he talks to
the Women's National Republican Club in
New York City for about an hour good
evening everyone and welcome to meet the
author I'm Catherine Lenihan and I chair
the library committee we are so pleased
to have Gordon cucuta as our guest
author this evening Gordon is a former
Special Forces and a green beret he's a
lieutenant colonel he served 20 years of
military service mostly in East Asia
later he was a staff officer at the
Pentagon in the office of the secretary
of defense he was selected for the
highly competitive George Marshall
exchange program and served in the
Department of State as political
military advisor for the Assistant
Secretary of East Asia Pacific affairs
Gordon has been a fox news channel
commentator since the SEPs in September
11th attacks and he has been on camera
analysis for W ABC TV in New York City
during the war in Iraq he is a regular
guest at WABC and the library
broadcasting radio and appears on many
talk radio programs across the country
he will answer questions after his
presentation and sign his books let's
give a warm welcome to Gordon Thank You
Katherine thank you for everybody happy
Veterans Day I'm delighted to be here I
can't tell you how excited I am to be at
the Women's National Republican Club on
Veterans Day indeed it's a great honor
and I really can't think of anyone any
group with whom I'd rather share the
experience then then the the people here
I mean it's just it's it's heartwarming
and I know that you as much as I do
appreciate the sacrifice of our men and
women and most especially because this
Veterans Day of 2004 we're a country of
war as a
of you know in fact you don't need to do
any more than flip on the radio or Fox
News Channel and you can see scenes of
fairly intense urban combat from
Fallujah we've got G is fighting
elsewhere in the country we've got
people in Afghanistan fighting and then
some of our guys who are comparative me
a generation or two past are fighting in
places that don't make the headlines and
getting a lot done on my dad I think
that you know years ago Brokaw wrote a
book called The Greatest Generation and
as much as I admire the war to
generation I mean that was my dad that
was my uncle that was a wonderful group
of people i must say that i think that
one of the things that makes this
country extraordinary and great is that
every generation becomes the greatest
generation because we always rise to the
new challenges when have we ever had a
more horrific challenge than we face
today and fortunately and this will be
probably well maybe not my last partisan
comment of the day but but at least the
first it's it was enormously a relief
and rewarding for me to see what
happened on November second here in this
country and on a lot of different levels
in one level i'm going to talk about
when we talk about the book and that is
a continuation of a policy that I think
works in Northeast Asia and I think that
you know certainly being a Northeast
Asian estai had a bit of an axe to grind
in the thing and that i was i was
extremely concerned with it and so we're
going to talk about that we'll talk
about that a little bit i'm going to
talk about the the book separated at
Birth throughout but before I do I want
to talk a little bit about our veterans
because this is their day on Fort well
I'm delighted that they pull the plug on
Yasser Arafat I have to say that's you
know that that's a long time coming and
you know there's a man who will be on a
slow spit in hell for
for a long time for the because he's a
terrorist and he killed a lot of nice
people on the other hand it's too bad
that he sort of pushed the vets off the
front page if he had been considerate he
would have done this yesterday or the
day before but I think what happened is
that they probably had to get the pin
number for the Swiss bank account first
after that it was no thanks no
respirator needed but you know
regardless that's another subject for
another night and I'd like to talk about
that but I really do you know lately
I've been going to a lot of these things
oh and by the way before I forget the
Women's National Republican Club today
this is my new york city launched for
separated at birth so I'm really excited
about that I can't think of as I said a
better place for veterans day in a
better place to kick this thing off
because I think it's a very important
work obviously I would I mean what the
heck I wrote the thing right but at the
same time being dispassionate and as we
talk about it throughout I'm going to
tell you why it's unique well I think
this is a very occupies a very special
place in in contemporary history and why
not only should you all have at least
your own personal copy but they're great
stocking stuffers to to sit and
Christmas gifts the the other thing too
in there is that when you get the book
and you look into the into the
dedication you're going to see that I
dedicated it to the Korean War vets and
I say you know the Forgotten War
forgotten no longer because that's how
we think of the Korean War if we think
about it at all as the Forgotten War
this was the war that fell in between
the euphoria of World War two which was
sort of the second war to end all wars
and the hysteria and protest the street
marches of Vietnam and these guys they
went they saluted the flag they did what
they had to do and when they came back
they put their uniforms in the closet
they hung him up and they went back to
work and they reintegrated into society
and society pretty much forgot about it
and so late an incident early in the
book my last tour of duty was at State
Department and which we in uniform used
to refer to somewhat fondly as the
reptile house
while there I was asked to dedicate a
korean war memorial in a little town in
central us and illinois called Mattoon
Illinois is everybody anybody ever heard
of Mattoon Illinois neither had I about
56 thousand folks you can't even get
there from here you have to fly
someplace else and they pick you up and
they drive you through more corn then
Carter's got little pills to get to this
place and it was a you know tuna fish
white bread fish finger sandwiches in
the VFW Club the night before but I was
able to Hera was in this place of all
things representing the US government
that's a little scary because they
wanted somebody to come out and talk to
him about the Korean War and what had
happened with the vets and there were a
lot of vets there that was it was a nice
group of people after we did the
memorial they had found and by the way
this little town of five six thousand
people had a memorial with 14 names of
people who had died on that memorial is
that a staggering percentage or what so
they they had done an excellent job of
finding the survivors the family for
these people and as they called out the
names at the conclusion of my
presentation which I talked about you
know how what an amazingly progressive
place South Korea was and how the
sacrifice of these men had meant that
millions and millions of people live in
economic and political freedom at that
time because of their sacrifice a few
remarks like that which candidly I
thought at the time were pretty lame but
as they call that the name this the
survivors had a red rose which they
placed on the memorial and were interned
given a white rose as am as a memory of
the incident so after it was over we're
all sort of milling around this gal came
up to me older woman and carrying a
white rose and of course you know being
a typical man I instantly panicked you
know I'm not going to deal with this and
she said introduced herself and said for
35 years I've been waiting for someone
to tell me why my son died you did just
now and I really appreciate it and you
know I was weepy I had tears coming out
my dad was award war two and Korean War
vet and unfortunately I lost him to
cancer a month after I came back from
Vietnam I think he hung on just long
enough for me to get home and I was ever
had the opportunity which I really
deeply wanted to take him back to Korea
when I went back both on you know for
working for Sam and later working for
General Electric when I went back over
there and could see this amazing
progress we're now 50 million people are
living in a free market democracy that
would never have happened had it not
been for the sacrifice of these Korean
War vets so say the Korean War vet or
the Korean War forgotten no more we've
got to remember this so if any of you
know anybody from the from the war or
see anybody give them a special
thank-you for me this day because I
think it's time we remembered them lots
of times when I go place people say
thank you for your service and candidly
when I came back in 72 I wasn't hearing
a whole lot of that as you might imagine
and there's reasons for it including
testimony that was given before Congress
in 1971 by certain failed presidential
candidate but it what happened was it
had toward a whole generation it really
did and then from that point on
Hollywood jumped in and we began to hear
this we begin to see this whole series
of strange films about you know that
we're all psychopathic drug users losers
couldn't integrate back into society
rapists drug addicts alcoholics and
those are the nice things so it was it
was a tough reintegration and we're
beyond that now now what we have is that
this amazingly professional Army Navy
Air Force and Marine Corps where these
kids frankly their head and shoulders
better than what we were they are really
really good at what they do we've also
got a guard and a reserve force that is
very committed to making things happen
we used to have a joke when I was on
active duty about National Guard weekend
you know a couple of kegs of beer and
carton of cigarettes and that was about
it no more these people are as
professional as the active
so when they come back because I know
New York has a lot of reservists and
guards people fighting over there make
sure you give them a special welcome I
know this group aI don't have to to give
much enthusiam Intuit naturally but tell
your friends i mean this is a sacrifice
and what these kids are doing on the in
the streets of Iraq and Afghanistan is a
net effect of bringing more than 50
million people to freedom and whether
you you know you were for the war
against the war neutral on the war kind
of doesn't matter we got it but the net
result i'm a results person i like to
see where we come out of it at the other
end i'm not much of a process person and
what we have right now is 50 million
people who are going to be able to
select their own rulers at some time and
what that's going to be is a very
positive domino effect in a region
that's been under 8th century
totalitarian fundamentalist islam for
well since the 8th century for almost 11
hundred years it's about time these
people caught a break and who's giving
it to him you and me and these GIS
there's another part of the world though
that bothers me a lot and that's why i
wrote separated at birth and i wrote
that by the way because of the
encouragement of my excellent literary
agent is sitting in the corner over
there joanne wang because she called one
day and said gee she and her husband
were down at barnes and noble they were
looking for something on north korea and
couldn't find anything in jim said Joe
and go ask Gordon if he can write a book
on North Korea and I really didn't want
to why because it's a terribly rotten
depressing place I mean who wants to
spend several months you know in effect
living in a garbage can I didn't want to
do that but after giving it some thought
I said you know there never has been
anything written that really compares
North Korea to South Korea it's all kind
of our history our politics everything
is real we it's like looking through the
back end of a telescope you know we
focus so much on the the the minutia
that we miss the big picture and I'm
kind of a big picture guy I don't know
if that's because i'm too lazy to be a
little picture guy or not but I kind of
like to look at the macro and not the
micro
and I said all right I'm going to tell
the story of North Korea I'm to tell it
in terms of South Korea why are 50
million people living in peace and
freedom and 22 million are starving in
gulag prison camps are fleeing for their
lives and are subject to human
experimentation with poison gases and
and biological agents under a regime
that wants nothing more than simply to
threaten its neighbors with nuclear
attack so that's what I did and I tried
to put it in the context in today's
context but more than that what I tried
to do and I want you all to give me
feedback on this and what I'm going to
do before this thing ends I'm going to
stick some business cards out here on
the table you can call or send emails or
you know carrier pigeon whatever but but
get the word to me and let me know this
is what I like this is what I didn't
like also I have a I do a lot of opinion
writing and I'm carried and some print
and some electronic media but i also
have a free a little subscriber thing
that i send out and so y'all can sign up
for that to the it kind of keeps you in
the loop and then when i am when i do
make personal appearances or I go
someplace then you'll know where it is
and you can either attend or avoid it at
your your leisure it's it's I believe in
a lot of free choices here the but what
I wanted to do was talk a little bit
about how Korea became Korea and then
where the policy in Korea is today where
I think it ought to go where we're on
course where we may need to tweak it a
little bit why this place is so
dangerous and then what I'd like to do I
like an interactive kind of thing so I'd
like to ask you all to to have a lot of
Q&A if if you don't mind okay because
that way it gives me a time to sort of
catch my breath the also I would like to
thank our friends at c-span who are here
tonight filming this and they did a
great job and and the
anywhere else do I get to ya pun
interrupted for an hour I mean this is
this is great I've got a captive
audience it's it's terrific so we well
as soon as I get through sort of you
know where I'd like to do to kind of T
this thing up to set this thing up for
y'all then then we'll do some we'll do
some cues and a's the I spent a lot of
time in Korea when I was a kid in Japan
and dad was back and forth to the war
that was when I first began to realize
there was a Korea when I came back in
nineteen sixty-nine to the region with a
green beret on my head set of jump wings
up there and thinking I could conquer
the world it was almost like coming home
there was a very interesting experience
everybody else felt like wow this is an
exotic place I felt like I was coming
home and then went to Korea shortly
thereafter and founder Korea that while
it wasn't the Korean War it was very
destitute very deprived they were under
a military authoritarian dictator
certainly ruler if not a dictator but
they had a long way to go and so I would
watch this and of course we were worried
day by day of an attack from the north
and candidly looking back from hindsight
had Kim il-sung the the the great leader
the original dictator of North Korea and
he decided to attack in the 60s when we
were tied up in Vietnam we probably
wouldn't have been able to stop him
unless we were prepared to go nuclear
and I'm not sure you know most of us I
can look around the room and see that
quite a few of us probably have
present-day memories of that time I
don't think we were politically inclined
to go that far on the mat with to save
South Korea in those days so like we
dodged a big bullet in those in that
time and we we inherited something that
we really hadn't hadn't tried to to
construct in the first place it was very
bizarre but but no one in 1947 I'm
jumped back for a second but I jump
around but y'all are a bright audience
and I know you can keep up with this
okay but no one in 1945 at the end of
the war thought that the war would end
before in the
Pacific before 1947 very few people knew
about the Atomics even the guys who had
done it out at Los Alamos weren't sure
that they were going to work we had
never actually dropped one from an
airplane and we weren't sure what the
effect was going to be on Japan you know
in their their cultural minds that would
they surrender or would we have to keep
pounding them we were looking at
horrendous casualties not only among the
American and Allied forces but most
particularly among the Japanese who
resided there anyone who doubts this
needs to look at the Battle of Okinawa
we're out of 200,000 Okinawan civilians
a hundred thousand were killed in that
battle and this was a portent this was a
flash forward of what Japan would have
looked like island after island
schoolchildren were already being told
you know stay of the Americans in the
gut with a pencil or a sharp chopstick
they'll kill you but what the heck you
die for the Emperor you know this sort
of thing so when when when the Atomics
came and suddenly we were prepared to to
move in to take over what happened was
that the Soviets were rushing down
through Manchuria with the object of
snatching off as much territory as they
can as they could at the time to people
Lieutenant Colonel Dean Rusk and another
officer who ended up being a four star
general in Washington at the time said
we've got to stop this let's draw the
line they picked a national geographic
map and if you look at one the 38th
parallel pretty well divides the country
in half it's a fairly easy spot to see
and so they put that forward in the
Soviet stopped there the u.s. came in to
take the surrender of the japanese south
of the parallel with the idea that with
the newly born UN there would be free
elections by 1948 in a unified country
we all know that didn't happen the
soviets came in the temporary line on
the ground became permanent tized they
put their own guy kim il sung in and he
began a cult of personality in a reign
of terror that has never been matched in
the face of the earth I mean this guy is
is was he had a cult of personality that
stolen and Mao would have admired they
would have said wow I wish we could get
that we could be that tough and then he
learned from them he set up a the gulag
system he set up prison camps and he
used the the two communist
allies of his the Soviets and the
Chinese very adroitly he walked a great
tightrope and he would say okay Moscow
look what I just got from Beijing and he
would say China look what I just got
from Russia and each one would try to
outbid the other 1988 the dynamics
changed with the fall of the Soviet
Union suddenly we had one bidder in the
auction and what happens when you only
have one bitter in the election it's
great for the buyer but lousy for the
seller so he didn't have anything to
sell anymore that anybody wanted to buy
and that's when the the Emperor was
truly discovered to have no clothes and
this so-called wonderful economic state
was exposed for the facade that it was
and it began to deteriorate and it's
been on a slippery slope and
increasingly steep slippery slope ever
since and that's a situation we have
today he was succeeded in 1994 when the
man finally died you know he had this
tumor on the back of his neck I can
remember back in 69 what else I didn't
have long to live you know this is it
he's just another couple months and he's
gone you know 94 the man lasted two and
and they quickly did what communist
regimes are fond of doing they sent him
over the taxidermist they got him all
stuff they put him in a mausoleum and
now you can you know for fifty cents you
can come and see him the and so there is
and everybody sort of admirers the great
leader but somehow he did something that
no communist ruler has ever been able to
do before and that is he arranged a
nepotistic succession for his son Kim
jong-il euphemistically known as the
dear leader so you had the great leader
now you have the dear leader the dear
leader has these delusions of grandeur
so he's now calling himself the great
general the great general the dear
leader is the one of the world's largest
the world's largest importer of
expensive French cognac he has chefs
that he sends around the world to get
lobsters from Southeast Asia to get
caviar from Iran to get sushi from Japan
to get you know I mean hot dogs from
nathans who knows
but meanwhile we've got two to three
million people who have starved to death
over the last few years in North Korea
we've got a gulag system which has more
than 200,000 people in it and there was
a German doctor there he was one of
these doctors without borders guys you
know you're all familiar with that
Norbert volar tson was his name and he
went there a couple years ago he you
know said gee these people are oppressed
I need to go help out one of his
patients had Turk was terribly burned
and needed skin graft and so he took
because there was no grafting material
he took a chunk of his own thigh skin
and grafted it onto this North Korean
patient and then was given he donned him
with a North Korean medal for that well
bulletin is a naturally curious kind of
pokey sort of person so he began to
drive himself around the country and he
used the metal as a get-out-of-jail-free
card to get through guards and get into
places where he shouldn't have seen and
they didn't want him to be and he
brought his camera with him and so the
series of pictures that came out of
there as he said as a German who bears
the guilt of the Holocaust what I saw in
those camps was so unnerving that it
shook him to his core he would see kids
that he initially thought were six and
seven years old there were 14 and 15 and
16 they were so malnourished and they
had those striped prison suits on that
that seemed to be the you know the
choice of all these dictators to have
their their their unfortunate prisoners
dress in he brought these pictures out
and and with a whole stream of horror
stories and I'm not going to regale you
with tonight but if you can imagine the
worst most of them are worse than that
and so when he began to drop this on the
world a lot of the the organizations
that were over there with bringing food
bringing assistance got very antsy
because with a lot of us had been saying
for years there's no transparency to
this relief system these things are
going in we were for some time the North
Koreans were the largest recipients of
food relief from the United States and
our allies in the world so why are
people starving if we're
pouring all this interim why are they
getting you know why are they freezing
when they're getting fuel why are they
you know why are they living in this
abject poverty without medicines why are
they dying at things that in our society
have been curable for four decades for
four generations and the reason is
because everything is being hoarded and
used to keep the army propped up because
without the army the dear leader is the
former dear leader and they'll string
them up by his heels just the same way
they did mussolini at the gas station in
northern italy which i incidentally
think is probably the highest and best
use of the dear leader but you know and
and that will come I have I call
Gordon's pressure cooker theory of
international relations which is that
the tighter the regime the one that when
the thing explodes the bigger the bone
and and the more repression you have
against the the dictators and you can
see it in Eastern Europe Hungary
Czechoslovakia transfer transferred
after the fall pretty good whereas in
East Germany and Romania they lined the
cs cubes up against the wall and use
them for target practice this is kind of
where I see this coming now we're in a
were in a policy position which thank
goodness is going to be continuous
that's what I talked about earlier for a
second and I'm kind of fast forward into
the presence that we'll have time for
some discussion on this but basically
what happened was in 94 the Clinton
administration was at the point where
they feared that they would be they
would have to actually go to war against
North Korea and we really weren't in a
position to do that because they were
scared of the nuclear program we knew
they were developing nukes in this case
it was plutonium they were refining
plutonium at young being up in the
northwest so at the last minute former
President Jimmy Carter got in an
airplane and flew out there and in what
can only be described and what I tried
to describe in the book as a very
bizarre situation was cooking deals with
Kim il-sung you know he was doing policy
off the hood of the limousine on the way
over to the palace and then in the White
House in the Oval Office you had this
amazing picture of the Clintons go
sandy Berger the the who was at Albright
everybody's sitting around the TV
watching Wolf Blitzer who's standing on
the White House lawn interviewing Carter
in Pyongyang via CNN I mean talk about a
lookingglass world they didn't know what
deal he had cooked and because he went
over there ostensibly they said well
you're going to have to go over as a non
official representative well anyone who
understands Asian culture and society
particularly communist Asia knows that
dog won't hunt you go over there and
you're the former president you must be
official there's no such thing as an
unofficial former president fact there's
no such thing as a living former
president in north korea but much less
an unofficial one so he could real quick
he cooked this deal the agreed framework
where he said okay you all will give us
Kim Kim il-sung said you all will give
us light water nuclear reactors because
poor us we don't have any power lots of
fuel oil to cover the gap and tons of
food and stuff because my soldiers are
hungry whoops i mean my people are
hungry so we did that and this went on
for a long time then we changed
administrations in two thousand and the
CIA the boys in the band came in and
brief the the the new team and said by
the way we're beginning to sniff what
looks like a continued nuclear R&D
program at this other site so James
Kelly who's our Assistant Secretary of
State for East Asia Pacific affairs
confronted the North Koreans and they
fessed up they said you're right you got
us with red handed we didn't do
plutonium we said we weren't going to do
plutonium but we didn't say we weren't
going to do in rich terranea so while
we're pouring all this food aid and keep
propping up this decrepit deplorable
regime they're over there making nuclear
weapons so we said okay that's not going
to work anymore we're not going to do
unilateral we're not going to go
bilateral we're going to go multilateral
we're going to involve all the important
players in the region and that's Russia
Japan South Korea North Korea course us
and who else China that's right and why
is it got to be China why do you think
their neighbors they're big they're Kim
il-sung's own or Kim Jong Il's only
friend in the world and we felt like
okay these guys have to be a player
because if everybody doesn't play then
the North Koreans are very adroit at
separating and splitting negotiating
parties out and they'll go say oh gee
did you know what he said about you and
wow you should see the deal we had its
back to the Soviet Chinese days again so
we said no we've got to have a united
front we've got to have everybody in
together and we've got all get on on
board we can have differing agendas to a
certain extent but we've got to have one
common agenda and that is that a nuclear
non-nuclear North Korea is unacceptable
along with this of course they've
developed very long range missiles if
you'd like to see a picture of one go
look at the latest military parade in
Syria or Iran and that's where you're
going to see him the TP threes that tip
young dome threes are going to be
capable of hitting the east coast of the
United States and Prudhoe Bay Japan is
already under the gun as his course of
south korea had saddam hussein had these
things you know i don't know if you
remember when the one the GIS were
rushing up the Tigris Euphrates valley
they found these missiles and errbody
said gee we didn't know you know our
great you and inspector said she didn't
know they had missiles well hello they
could have hit every capital in Western
Europe and if he had stuck a dirty bomb
or some bugs or gas on top of one of
those think what that would have done
along with would it have done if it hit
Jerusalem or Tel Aviv so we've got to
get these guys out of the missile export
business there are other big export the
only other big export other than WMD or
missiles is heroin and methamphetamines
in a nation that's starving they've made
the farmers convert thousands of
hectares of agricultural land over to
opium so they can refined it in the
heroin and send it down into Southeast
Asia and Australia they're probably also
sending it to places like South America
where it gets flipped and then comes up
here into the United States that's their
big sources of income I mean really
wonderful people to have to deal with
fortunately the Japanese are working
with us there
the cash transfer that was going from
the in western Japan from the Japanese
Yakuza or the Korean yonkers are the
gangsters that were there they're not
having a real blockade but what they're
doing is finding that there's an
extraordinary number of safety
violations on Korean North Korean ships
at port in Japan so sometimes they can't
get out for months and months until the
certainly until the inspectors find the
dope or whatever contraband is on there
so we're working together not only do we
have these six party people but we've
also got the Aussies who by the way it's
appropriate to mention the Australians
on Veterans Day these guys have been
with us through thick and thin and every
war we've had since World War one I mean
what wonderful people were wonderful
allies and and you know thank God howard
got reelected with a good majority
gained a couple seats out you know
you're not going to you know maybe I'm
from I come from a Spanish background
I've got to say that I was embarrassed
at that but you know by George we don't
threaten and the Australians don't
threaten you know it's sort of like okay
bring it on you know we'll take care of
you and and that was our reaction of the
bin Laden tape that was there as to the
attack on the embassy in Jakarta but
regardless we've got a good thing going
with this the six power talks and then
our backup you know Tony Blair's behind
this too they're not at the table but
you can bet you they're right behind a
table and that's what we really need
here we've got to keep its i call it the
Anaconda strategy I don't know any of
you all over it's a sort of a strange
subject but the way an anaconda kills
its prey I did you know I thought well
it just squeezes it right but it doesn't
snakes pretty smart it wraps but then
when the prey exhales it just tightens a
slight bit and then when the prey
exhales again it tightens a slight bit
so you end up suffocating they try to
don't you know don't try this at home
but it's a it's a scary kind of thing
and that's exactly what we're trying to
do with the six-party people on North
Korea which is just you know when he
exhales we squeeze in a little tighter
we squeeze in a little tighter we we
intercept the ships with the contraband
on it you know we I don't know if you
remember that
turned off the pipeline for three days
not too long ago the fuel pipeline they
said technical difficulties what a
wonderful excuse technical difficulties
given you know whether the phone goes
out of the gas or you know the subway
doesn't run or you don't get fuel its
technical difficulties there's no
technical difficulties in Northeast Asia
everything's a message and the message
was dumb pushes too hard sports fan
because we've got you know we've got our
hand on the lever I'm not this is
strictly Kaku use opinion this is
nothing nobody in the in the business
but I wouldn't be surprised that there
were Chinese fingerprints on the train
wreck back in May June remember that one
where the the train unexpectedly blew up
and then this mysterious explosion that
we thought you know wow that was a
mushroom cloud because that was where
they do the solid fuel Rockets and it
wouldn't surprise me a bit if a Chinese
fire cruise missile took that bad boy
out I think they're getting their
patience is running to an end but part
of what I tried to do and separated at
birth is to talk about how this whole
thing lays out from you know picked it
up from the beginning kind of gave you
some insight into what the culture and
the history of Korea was without being
too hell heavy-handed on it how the
division came up what happened out of
the war and what I've tried to do which
I think that makes makes this book
unique is that I've tried to take a
macro overview and show when certain
things happened why other things
happened and I think I'm the only ones
that so far that I've read anyway and
you know I've read a little bit in the
field that that has linked up some of
these things for example in 1976 we saw
more internal repression in South Korea
we saw a move for them to develop their
own defense industries within which they
had never done before and we saw a
beginning of an erosion of the bilateral
relationship well what happened in 75
anybody remember what happened in April
1975 we had kicked off the embassy roof
in Saigon we abandon allies that we had
told will fight you to the death or will
fight for you to the death the president
told him that Congress pulled the rug
out from under him a few months later we
have a presidential candidate who says I
want to withdraw
of the troops unilaterally from South
Korea and the president Park at the time
was begging him and open to op eds which
they never do over there this is going
to generate another attack you can't do
this you know you pretending to save a
little money what it's going to do is
cost maybe millions of lives and
billions and billions of dollars in
wasted resources please don't do this
you know we got him talked out of it and
then right after that dessert everybody
anybody remember the Korea gates candles
I mean the media's got to stick a gate
on any day I'm thing now but but you
know the Korea gates candles well you
know connect the dots we'd pull the
Congress pull the rug out from under
South Vietnam we had a president who
would look like he was going to pull the
rug out from under South Korea what do
the South Koreans going to do they're
going to try to buy some congressmen me
what the heck everybody else has their
own you know why can't we have a few and
they got caught and so you know it's
it's these kind of trends that I try to
to put together in the book and I try to
do it an entertaining way so I can't
stand a boring book so if this book is
boring send me an email and I'll
apologize but I don't think you'll find
it boring i I've had several comments
and they've said which I take as
compliments Jesus reads like fiction you
know it's a page-turner it's exciting
I've got a few of my own personal you
know kind of war stories in there which
as a very humble person it was tough for
me to put in but I did anyway but you'll
get a kick out of them I'm sure you will
so at this point I'd like to kind of
open this to be a little more
interactive because you guys have been
rather patient for too long yes please
Barbara
no you're okay Gordon first of all I'd
like to say that I really happy that I
came this evening you really are a
stupendous and your information at this
time in history is going to be
invaluable and I'm sure they'll have a
great success with your book just
because it's so timely and this war on
terror I want all the viewers please in
this war on terror is the assumption the
real truth that North Korea actually is
the left toe of China or is there any
real independence that's a good question
the you know this wheels within wheels
in this whole war and terror thing but I
think one thing we can all agree on is
as a point of departure is that
certainly North Korea aptly deserve to
be included in the axis of evil a lot of
people at the beginning said well this
was just so that we wouldn't finger too
many Islamic states but that really
isn't it you know we as Americans tend
to be somewhat bifurcated you know we
think well if you're this then you're
not that and so we were too focused on
the Islamofascists side of the war on
terror and not enough focus on what
these tangential countries are doing to
support it but if you look the guy con
that we busted up in Pakistan he in the
North Koreans were working hand in glove
on a nuclear program they're working
with the Iranians today the North
Koreans that we've got reports of
Syrians that have been found in North
Korea they're cooking some kind of stuff
up this is a web that's under the radar
that that is very frightening and we
need to be bright enough and
sophisticated enough to realize that it
is an international organization or it
excuse me an international movement not
really an organization we're Americans
and so we tend to look for organizations
we need to look for movements and it
doesn't matter if they don't share the
same ideology or philosophy they do
share one thing and that is they all
want us dead and they all want to impose
their will on Western civilization and
if they have a
after we're out of the picture then
they'll worry about that at that time
that's their philosophy the other side
of it is as I mentioned before is that
North Korea is so destitute and so broke
that they would literally sell anything
they could to try to get some sort of
hard hard currency in there I think the
Chinese are the kind of people that like
to stand back and watch over all this
you know they call themselves the Middle
Kingdom and they like to watch all this
develop and they like to be the ones
that are pulling the puppet strings but
at the same time I think Kim jong-il has
embarrassed the Chinese he's caused
disharmony in an area where they don't
want disharmony the last thing the North
or the Chinese want is a proliferation
of nuclear weapons capabilities
throughout the countries in the region
that at this point don't have them Japan
South Korea Taiwan because that fly in
the Chinese loin Minh teens that
reunification or absorption of Taiwan
doesn't get done this century and may
not get done the next now for us we say
century you know but that's how these
guys think they have a much longer
horizon than we do so I think that that
while there's some attempt from the
Chinese to control Kim jong-il I also
think that he's off the reservation on a
lot of things does that answer your
question thank you anything else yes
please
gives you time to think about what does
South Korea really want I think a lot of
us know that West Germany is not
ecstatic with the unification of east
germany and i see that same scenario
should North Korea ever decide to join
you know South Korea I think it'd be a
matter of months before South Koreans
would go oh my god now we have to
support these guys in west germany you
hear that over and over they want that
wall back up you see that happening that
it's a very sophisticated question and
in fact that we don't have to wait till
it happens we're already hearing and now
the what happened was when in South
Korea what we used to hear all the time
was reunification now okay then the wall
came down east germany in west germany
came together the South Koreans talked
to their pals in in Berlin and got
sticker shock when they ran the numbers
on what North Korea reunification would
do there I mean they were they were
stunned and then it became reunification
later reunification later right and then
I think a really delicious thing began
to happen in 1996 19 or 1997 1997 kim
jong our kim dae-jung who was the very
lefty kind of opposition party member
for years became president and when he
did he opened what he called a sunshine
policy to North Korea I have it on good
faith from a source here in the United
States a South Korean intelligence agent
who defected to us because he's so
afraid for his life because he he has
sworn that he was responsible among
others for distributing up to 1.5
billion US dollars from South Korea to
North Korea to bring North Korea to the
bargaining table in the period from 1997
to year two thousand to pretend to be
all kissy face with South Korea so that
kim dae-jung would be nominated for and
eventually win the Nobel Peace Prize
which he did also the Nobel Committee
got a lot of largesse out of that too
many of them would come to north south
korea and be wined and dined and leave
with a fatter swiss bank account which
apparently in the international
community is no big deal because
certainly the UN is sitting in a you
know an excellent example for this
someone said the other day the coalition
of the bribed is you know France Germany
Russia and China but I digress the
what's happened is that the successor
for kim dae-jung no mohandas the current
president has continued this bogus
sunshine policy and what they have done
in effect is turn a blind eye toward the
incredible amount of suffering that's
going on among the people in North Korea
there are even cutting deals where
they've got the so-called free trade
zones where they use North Korean slave
labor for products that they're then or
OEM stuff that comes down to South Korea
and then as later exported I think that
this is something that is beginning at
last to prey on the conscience of many
honest and ethical citizens of South
Korea who realized that we can no longer
pretend that this isn't happening and
you know for those of you I know Barbara
some others have told me that you've got
parents or relatives who were
concentration camp graduates and you
know we in this country and and other
places around the world we've been down
this road before folks you know where we
pretended that horrors weren't going on
and that they didn't affect us you know
it's not my backyard at somebody else we
can't do that anymore and that's why I
think that our policy toward North Korea
has to be inclusive as far as the
multiple the multilateral side of it if
we go back to bilateral it's we're
condemning these people to death and
we're going to get nothing done
multilateral but at the same time we
need to make sure that human rights is
on the table with any sort of nuclear or
WMD disarmament they have to go hand in
glove and many of you may not have
followed because of the intensity of the
election height going on recently but
about 23 weeks ago Congress
and this is quite amazing to me in the
middle of this intense election campaign
that we had both houses of Congress
unanimously passed the North Korean
Freedom Act which was then immediately
signed by the President and a law and
basically what that says is that any
dealing with North Korea must requires
transparency of all foreign aid that's
given out so that we know that it's not
going the foods not going to the army or
up to the Chinese border on the black
market it requires that transparency and
human rights dealings and we we have
active solicitations for the welfare of
the refugees who have escaped into China
who are now being forcibly repatriated
and when they come back there they're
asked two questions have you did you
come in contact with any South Koreans
did you come in contact with any
Christians because both of those
ideologies democracy and Christianity
are anathema to Kim jong-il if the
answer to either one is yes they go into
the camps and very few come out if the
women are pregnant there they are
forcibly aborted with high pressurized
salt water if they manage to bring a
baby to term the babies killed in front
of them these are not it's not a pretty
picture it's not a pleasant activity and
it's way past time for the South Koreans
to get on board with this and realize
what's happening and I think they have
an election at 07 and I'm looking
forward to that I think that we've got a
good chance of that is is more of a
ground swell of conscience among Koreans
right down south koreans yes ma'am what
role is the South Korean government
playing in our negotiations with North
Korea today it seems to me that at
certain times you know they they want to
have their cake and eat it too and it's
not clear to me whose side they're
really on I think they're on their own
side and I don't mean to be flippant
that they're they're trying to walk a
tightrope between where this is eluding
you know part and parcel the answer I
gave before but I think that what
they're trying to do is is exactly what
you said it's a cake and eat it
situation they want to pretend to be
for reunification do that they're
worried about these people in the north
and they also want to take advantage of
the people in the north and they also
want to be they have a bit of an ostrich
attitude toward it if I ignore it it'll
all go away and it won't hurt me and
part of this is is is manifests itself
and what you see among the the ruling
party the hoodie party which means our
party that's no mu Hyun who inherited
the sunshine policy from kim dae-jung is
that they're acting as if they that the
u.s. and North Korea our enemies and
that they South Korea don't have a dog
in the fight and that's highly delicious
Richard Allen who was a former national
security adviser for president nixon has
said that he finds that an absolutely
reprehensible attitude for the North
Korea are for the South Koreans to take
where they've sort of inserted
themselves in is that they're going to
be honest brokers or mediators here and
that's not going to work that and so
with the if we went back to a bilateral
policy they could very well sit in that
place and it would be hard to dislodge
them but with a multilateral six-party
plus policy I think we've got them in a
position where they'll have to face
reality and the the opposition party the
Conservative Party in South Korea is
beating this drum louder and louder in
fact the ER tea party the ruling party
in south korea had actually opposed the
North Korean Freedom Act whereas the the
opposition party was was doing
everything they could to raise awareness
of the ramifications of the act in South
Korea and giving very vocal support for
it all over so I think we've got friends
in South Korea it's time for them to
regain power which they will they've had
five free and you know elections and
peaceful transitions of power they're
just like us I mean you know that you go
through the waves somebody comes
somebody goes but now I think finally
they're there they're ready to step up
to a new level of maturity and I hope
they do I'll be very proud of them if
they do that
I'm still here anything else would you
like to do to talk about yes please we
we have a follow-up i'll let you have
more than one today okay so how do the
South Koreans really feel about the fact
that rums Ville is realigning everyone
and we have a lot of men coming out of
South Korea finally at last I can't wait
I thought that's a good question too
because the I think it may have given a
wake-up call that was long overdue I
think we were taken for granted frankly
you know it's okay you know they're here
they're going to be here and if we want
to just sort of be disrespectful and and
somewhat pouty and and whiny and have
our little fits of temper from time to
time they're not going to do anything
about it because it's in their best
interest to stay and then what happened
is that you know it was sort of like a
shock wave that hit everybody when
Rumsfeld said oh I think we're going to
realign with the heck we've got a new
war we got new strategy here and by the
way south korea you're going to have to
be carrying a lot more of the water than
you carry it in the past and you know
let's pull our guys back about a couple
hundred miles behind the dmz where
they're sitting targets for these North
Korea and artillery pieces will be a
quick reaction force and oh I'm going to
need a brigade to to go fight the war
because you know you guys are giving us
a hard time now let me say in defense of
South Korea they've got 3,000 g is in
Iraq they're not combat there a combat
engineer unit which as many of you know
you know they build stuff but they get
shot at they get captured the Koreans
have had a hostage taken and killed
murdered by the sarkar we're at so we
need not to be too hard on them I mean
they have been good allies they are good
allies they will continue to be good
allies but sometimes I mean you know you
have to when we're when we're walking a
moral high road which in my opinion we
have been since
eight o'clock in the morning of sep
tember 11th then we need to make sure
that our friends and allies join us in
those standards and we need to encourage
them to do that without being
paternalistic or dictatorial and so I
think what this was in effect was a way
of saying it's not 1953 anymore it's not
1973 it's 2004 going on 2005 and we've
got a world at war and we need to
readjust our forces I am you know this
isn't exactly that you know the question
you asked but you know it's hard to shut
me up sometimes when I'm going I think
this whole force structure realignment
is absolutely wonderful first place I'd
move them as out of Germany maybe into
Poland whose have been a great friend in
Eastern Europe but I like the idea of
consolidating families and facilities in
the US and keeping the soldiers in the
same units and then sending those units
in and out as they need to go one of the
huge mistakes were made in vietnam and
we made a couple but one of the huge
ones we made in vietnam was the
individual rotation policy where you
would you would go in you'd go into a
unit that was already there you'd leave
and you know and people would continue
to do that if you notice what we're
doing in Iraq and Afghanistan is that
like 3rd infantry will go in 3rd
infantry will come out 82nd goes in
Marine Corps comes in you know it's just
we change them out like this and it's
much better because then anybody who's
ever been in service or even on a sports
team you learn to love and rely udderly
on your buddies and your friends and it
transcends friendship I mean he gets a
Steve Ambrose in his book band of
brothers you know which was the Henry
the fifth quote had it he nailed it i
mean that's exactly what it was and and
that's exactly how it is my dearest
friend today was with me in special
forces in Vietnam he lives in Atlanta 60
years old he's got a four year old in a
two year old and I said Gina
about time you begin to think more in
terms of grandparenting here bless his
heart he's been a dear friend but we've
stuck together and everybody does and
that's how these kids are doing today
and they know when they kick in a door
or throw in a grenade or walk down one
of these streets who's in front of them
who's behind them and they don't ever
have to look to check and you can't buy
that folks I mean you know that and and
that's so that's one of the good things
but I think I'm excited about a lot of
the things that the Pentagon is doing
that there's a couple of things I'd like
to see i'd like to see housecleaning at
state I'd like to see housecleaning at
CIA I think both of those organizations
have become anachronistic particularly
the State Department they're still
selecting and recruiting in the ways
that they did in the 1920s and 30s I
think it's time to get them into the
21st century or at least into the late
20th for a while and and the agency the
boys in the band is we affectionately
know them I think they need to get get
an overhaul too so we're we're not so
dependent on gadgetry and we've become
more into the spy business in the way
the classical sense that we used to be
where we had if not boots on the ground
then sandals on the ground or burgers on
the ground or something but somebody to
give us this information because right
now we don't I mean if we can't
photograph it or sniff it with an
infrared sensor we don't know it's there
and we can't that's that's unacceptable
in this kind of war this shadow war kind
of thing so anything else yes ma'am
probably this is one of the most
difficult wars that we've ever had to
face and that we probably will ever have
to face and I think our boys are going
through a terrible terrible terrible
time and I see the yellow ribbons on
back of cars support our troops and
that's very nice but lately there's been
a lot of TV programs showing our boys in
hospitals whether they're a year with no
legs and no arms and and there don't
have money for their wives to go and
visit them they're allowed to go by our
government they'll give them two hundred
fifty dollars a day for one week they'll
give them a round trip ticket they can
take one person with them
all very very young they have very young
wives and they have young babies that
they don't see and I don't understand
why more can't be done to get more funds
to get these families together so at
least they can visit with them and stay
with them while they're going through
getting new legs and new arms yeah I
don't know one Association that's doing
any fundraising maybe there is one I
don't know where it is I can tell you a
couple of them but I do agree i think
it's an excellent point and what better
day to you know other than veterans day
to raise something like that it breaks
my heart frankly because you know these
kids as you said i mean we're talking
about what age 19 to 24 probably one or
two babies young wife herself may be
very unsophisticated in being able to
act independently and and in many cases
this is where we do i think the military
kind of drops a ball I mean we take care
of the member but we don't really take
care of the family as much and and one
of the things i like more about what I
spoke to you about you know this
consolidation kind of thing is that we
would have these unit the you know the
family units the friendship units the
support units all in one place the there
are organizations as a Freedom Alliance
which Ollie north is working hard on
there's what's called the the warrior
foundation that's mostly for the Special
Ops guys of all services there's
returning heroes org these sorts of
things if you ding me on my website and
you can get that off of the it's a
complicated website it's Colonel Gordon
calm if you can enter all spelled out
Colonel Gordon calm if you go to that
you'll see a lot of these organizations
are on my links there and I'm not in the
government anymore I can't answer that
but it is something that needs to be
done and you know we've got you know
we've got a process here we've got
senators we've got representatives it's
not out of the question to now that we
you know with for the history of the
last couple months maybe it's a good
time to raise this sort of thing I mean
we do a lot of
we do a lot overseas I think we need to
make sure we don't forget our own in
this process I must say I think we're
about ready to pull the plug on here and
I must say it's been a delightful
evening I've had a great time I hope you
have to and thank you for your attention
Thank You Gordon for a wonderful
presentation and his book is fascinating
and so informative it's a wonderful
wonderful rock absolutely and we are so
pleased yes we are so pleased that you
were our guests over there wonderful
what a wonderful great audience and a
great place to be so thank you can't
think of a better place for veterans day
yes just as aspiring no not really it's
too much thank you appreciate it
wonderful Gordon hmm yes it's just
Gordon Kaku Lou is a former US Army
Green Beret as a frequent commentator
for Fox News separated at birth is
published by lyons press get information
online at lyons press com